right there's a sitcom with Mickey
Rooney Nathan Lane in New York Mickey
Rooney Mickey Rooney you read his book
no I know Mickey though oh he passed
away didn't he he did but he made it to
like 95. yeah dude did you hear about
the story where something he slept at
somebody's house for like a couple weeks
right yeah oh no he let somebody stay in
his house for a couple weeks he was
married to some like bombshell right
yeah he he
all six of the hottest stars in the
world and I said Mickey how'd you get
him he goes money makes you handsomer
money makes you handsomer is his own
word but go ahead what was his story a
guy stated his face for a couple of
weeks and he left him a couple paintings
as a gift and they were uh and then like
a few months later he was getting a
divorce or something and so his friend
helped him move and he said oh you can
have those somebody left him here and
they were Salvador dollies they were two
Salvador Dali paintings wow and he
talked about struggling with his with
money most of his life oh yeah and uh
and then here he was giving away a
couple dollars like that it's just kind
of crazy yeah there he is right there
there is one oh there I am it's the
tallest I've ever been Mickey's like he
called himself I'm a fire plug you know
built like a fire and Nathan Lane and
that he was my grandfather and I was
just cast uh from NBC I got a deal
freakly I had a teen idle thing going on
and go you're gonna play Mickey Rudy's
grandson in New York and then I met
Nathan and Mickey thought I was gay the
whole time he would put his arm around
Nathan and look at me and go I'm just
glad we like girls
and he finally got money because he was
broke for 50 years anyway he was Rooney
was broke I called up Warner Brothers in
1955. I said this is Mickey Rooney he
was always doing this I need a job
and he'd stare off and he'd go he hung
up on me
and then you'd come into the the the
studio and you'd hear him down the hall
how long is Rod from Robert Redford been
in the business he's one of those guys
who talked till he ran out of air how
long has Robert Redford been in the
business 10 years I've been in the
business 62 years how old are you 62 in
two months I mean he's one of those guys
who's a baby oh yeah he had so many he
would said this a thousand times
literally literally he would say this
every day
I was the which he was he was the number
star number one star in the world 1937.
I was the number one star in the world
you hear me bang
the world and he did that you hear me
bang the world
but he had finally had money he was
doing a Broadway show on our show he
went to the racetrack all week it was
old show business we had a guy who was
five feet tall his head was and we would
just rehearse with him all week but
Mickey would have like five thousand
dollars and he'd put it in front of my
face and goes think I can afford lunch
and he had a 38. he didn't like the
script he would bring it out
and he throw the script this script is
Kaka and he's wavering there's 38 around
and he puts it back in he goes they're
not gonna get me who well he was going
to kill Juan Corona this serial killer
before this I was gonna go to see Juan
Corona and I say you know why
I am full of holes
he was the craziest greatest he would
play a piano because he was a jack of
all trades his piano chords he goes this
is Stephen sondheim's favorite song but
then we bonded he thought I was a hack
and an idiot but then
I was able to do Jimmy Stewart porn so
that's when I when I got him how are you
doing Mick yeah good good to say uh and
said he was an impressionist too he's
like Sammy Davis Jr just could do
anything
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one